John, Tommy, congratulations.
You fellas have made
it into the final round
of this competition.
It's time to step up your
games and make something worthy
of a "Forged in Fire" champion.
Now it's time to send you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the M 1832
foot artillery sword.
You'll have four
days at your home
forge in which to
complete this challenge.
At the end of your
four days, you'll
return and present your weapons
to our panel of expert judges.
And after they've tested
the hell out of them,
you guys will graduate
from child's play
to full-fledged "Forged
in Fire" champion
who wins a check for $10,000.
Good luck, blade smiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Back here in my shop, here
in Gainesville, Texas, and I'm
taking on the M 1832
foot artillery sword.
Today I want to get
the basics forged out.
I'm using a car leaf
spring because I
use the leaf spring a lot.
It makes a really good blade.
It hardens really well.
And it tempers really well.
My secret weapon for moving
this metal, 8-pound hammer.
Why?
Everything's bigger in Texas.
That's why.
My cane's a little off
center, so I had to fix it.
I'm going to throw it
in the hydraulic press
to get it centered out.
A little lower.
She's a little ugly,
but she moves metal.
That's all that matters.
Oh, perfect!
Woo-hoo!
Today I'm going to get
working on the handle.
I'm going to be putting a lot of
my own twist into this weapon.
So I'm making a
cast bronze handle.
In order to cast
this out of bronze,
I've got to make a
positive, regardless.
So I could use any type of wood.
I can use clay.
This is just a really easy
material to work with.
So the idea is that the metal is
going to travel down this tube.
It's going to fill
this handle up.
It's going to come down
the bottom, fill these up.
And those will come out in
the mold as cast bronze.
So this is a razor
tip wood burner.
I'm going to use this to put
the dragon scale texture.
This handle's going to
take longer than the blade
when it's all said and done.
But I think it's going
to be well worth it.
Love it.
Looks great.
Yesterday I put it in
the forge and quenched.
So I'm going to start
forging the garden pommel.
Get her done!
Using a piece of round
stock mod steel--
nothing special, but it works.
Looks good.
So grinding is what
I'm going to do next.
I'm here in round three.
So happy I'm in round
three to begin with.
And build, so far,
is going really good.
[bleep]
My blade goes through, and
it catches on the belt.
It has happened to me
in a similar situation,
where it's catastrophic.
This stupid thing.
I have a curl in my actual edge.
I have to match the rest of the
edge to that lower point now.
If I don't, this could
potentially be a weak spot.
Just going to grind it out.
Nothing I can do
other than that.
Just gotta roll with adversity.
Today I have to finish
getting the handle cast.
I've got the original build.
Now I need to make
the mold for it.
So this is casting the sand
that holds shape really well.
So what I'm going to
do is us pack this down
into the bottom of my flask,
lay my positive in there,
and then pack it
in nice and tight.
That's awesome.
So I've got my two halves now.
Now I'm ready to put
them back together
and get them out to the foundry.
I've got some bronze that I'm
going to start melting down.
Once those get into
a molten state,
then we'll be ready to pour.
The first time you're
casting any design,
there's always a lot of
issues that can come out.
You know, the metal could
cool down too much before it
gets down to the bottom.
The mold could
collapse on itself.
It could just wreck inside,
and I don't know it.
All right, if this
doesn't work, I'm screwed.
A bad pour is going to set
me back at least half a day.
I really don't have
that time to spend.
Whoa!
That was 3,000 degrees of
metal hitting 60-degree water.
Here she is.
Hoo!
The cool thing about bronze is
that there's no carbon in it.
So you don't have to worry about
cracking or anything like that.
I came here to prove that
I can deliver more than I
did in the first two rounds.
And I'm really excited to show
the judges what I've done.
A $10,000 sword, if
I've ever seen one.
To find out what
kind of deadly force
your artillery
swords can supply,
I will take your weapon,
deliver killing slashes
on this ballistics dummy.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Ready.
[impact sounds]
I like the beauty of an
all-metal construction.
And the Damascus pattern
you have here is gorgeous.
The weight-- it's all
the way in the handle--
allows for a good recovery and
forward delivery of strikes.
Your edges are very sharp.
Every cut cuts deep, cuts to
the bone and into the organs.
And most importantly,
sir, it'll kill.
Thank you.
All right, Tom, your turn.
You ready?
Get her done.
[impact sounds]
The weight of your
weapon is all forward,
that it actually
takes a lot to pull
it away for a second strike.
But the thing that your beast
does have is a very sharp edge.
Every cut is very deep.
But it takes a lot of work
to control this beast.
More importantly, though,
sir, it will kill.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now, why bring swords
to a gun range?
Well, so you two can join
one of our two clubs,
the "oh, my god, they broke
my blade with a bullet"
club or the
bulletproof sword club.
So to test your
blades, we've got
our firearm locked in a vise.
We've got your blade locked
in another vise down range.
We're gonna fire one
round at that thing.
It should split that bullet
clean or, worst of all,
see that blade shatter.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Yep.
OK.
Fire.
[gunshot]
Four holes.
You can actually see top
and bottom where that bullet
went across your blade.
And you can see there's four
holes in the thing over there.
That's the lead
core and the jacket
going in different directions.
So you split that bullet nicely.
I don't see any
damage to your blade.
Well done.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Tommy,
are you ready for this?
Let's do it.
Fire.
There we go.
All right, Tommy, well,
your blade took some damage
in that bullet test.
There's a chip in one spot.
And the other spot you can
actually hear my fingernail
catching on that roll.
Having said that, it
doesn't feel bad in my hand.
But it is very heavy
for this type of sword.
But as far as the strength test
goes, as you can clearly see,
it took some damage.
All right, blade
smiths, now that we
know your blades
can take a bullet,
it's time to find
out if they can cut.
This is the sharpness
test, the shot bag slice.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yep.
[impact sounds]
Good job, man.
[chuckling]
It is fun to wield.
It is fun to move around.
It cuts with every slice.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Tom,
it's your turn, sir.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[impact sounds]
Awesome.
All right, Tommy, on
the stationary cuts,
it cuts cleanly.
It's a sharp blade.
Now, when I'm moving around
and changing my balance because
of the weight of
the blade, it does
affect the way I'm cutting.
So some of the cuts are not
clean all the way through.
There are some strands.
More importantly, your
weapon here, though a beast,
it will cut.
John, Tommy, the judges have
made their final decision.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
John, congratulations, you are
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Thank you.
It feels great to be the next
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Good job, brother.
I'm super proud of all
the work that I've done.
I've come here and
done tasks that I never
would have expected
from myself, put
myself into challenges that I
never would have tried before.
And I've succeeded,
so I feel awesome.
[theme music playing]